what on Earth happened Chesney good
morning good morning Kay how are you
doing nice I am good tell me what
happened
uh well I was flying from Greece uh I
was performing at a wedding uh and I was
with my wife and we were um halfway from
Greece to Barcelona where I was going to
do some shows in Spain
and uh the plane uh just uh started to
to drop and everybody's uh ears started
to go
um and uh the stewardess there's no easy
way of saying this she completely uh
lost her mind and was running down the
aisle screaming at everybody telling him
to put their masks on and
um and uh everyone started to kind of
panic around us and uh it was a crazy
scene she um this went on for quite a
while actually
um everybody started panicking and and
then the the
um the captain came over the
loudspeakers and said emergency dissent
emergency descent brace brace uh and of
course this is the last thing you want
to hear uh when you're 37 000 feet up
um and it was uh it was a very kind of
terrifying ordeal and my wife and I just
kind of looked at each other uh and and
had this kind of moment of oh this is is
this it is is this How This Ends uh
meanwhile the stewardess is now a
feature position on the floor uh with
her mask on
and she she's screaming at this guy who
was filming there's a lot of people
filming obviously in moments like this
modern day uh things like this people
filmed don't they with their phones and
um the the stewardess just was screaming
at her saying the plane's going down
we're all gonna die and you're filming
it's like
it's just just crazy stuff and uh
honestly goodness and I looked out the
window and the plane's like on its side
looking down at the at the sea and
honestly thought that was it and uh you
know my wife and I were like we have to
we have to this could be it so we have
to tell the kids we love them you know
it's the first thing that came into our
heads was we've got to we've got to
leave a message for the kids so we
opened up our WhatsApp group with our
with our kiddos and we was we just said
you know we don't know what's happening
the planes seems to be going down we
love you uh we're proud of you please
look after each other it was really like
a harrowing you know and Chrissy my wife
was just absolutely calm as a cucumber
and I was like a blubbering mess
when will you get on a plane again
Chesney well we I've already gone I've
already been on a plane since I got
straight on the horse uh okay because we
had to fly because we had it was an
emergency landing in in Napoli
um so we had to fly from Napoli to
Barcelona on the same plane I'm not the
same plane that the same kind of plane
with the same passengers and a different
crew and there was the moment when we
were actually you know they were doing
the safety demonstration and uh the
steward uh said uh he was like um in the
unlikely event that the masks come
because that's the other thing that
having the mask came down you know we
were all had our masks on there I forgot
to mention that you know my wife's like
we already know
all the passengers were shouting yeah it
was a crazy experience wow we read about
it in the paper last week Chesney and we
just wanted you to come on and tell us a
bicep but you know the likelihood of
that happening apparently is
but when it does happen my goodness me
anyway we're glad to see that you are
alive and well and gave us an
opportunity to play your music again
thanks for taking the time thank you for
having me on care you take care lots of
love you too my love you too